good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight say what you want about the 2020
presidential race it's not what they
used to call a managerial election it's
not a contest to determine which branch
of the establishment gets a turn at the
wheel this isn't a Clinton dole 96 kind
of race where you're pretty sure that no
matter who wins things aren't really
gonna change very much this year the one
thing you can be certain of is that
things could be very different when it's
over the issues at stake are bigger than
just the economy or even our foreign
policy commitments 2020 is about the
broadest possible questions what kind of
country should we have who should live
here what will America will look like 50
years from now there are a lot of
possible answers to those questions but
leading Democrats appear to have settled
on their position America they're
telling us should be a lot more like
California listen to former New York
Mayor Michael Bloomberg explain his
vision for the country he's hoping to
lead I think that California can serve
as a great example for the rest of this
country you have led the way on climate
change on fighting gun violence and on
criminal justice and you have as
importantly open immigrants with open
arms
California is a part of this country
that is something the rest of the
country looks up to
so Michael Bloomberg graduated from high
school almost 60 years ago and at that
time a lot of what he just said was true
the rest of the country really did look
up to California millions of Americans
moved to California in search of a
better life it had the nation's best
public schools in at world-class
universities that essentially were free
graduates from those universities
created Silicon Valley among other
things the birthplace of the digital age
compared to the rest of America poverty
in California then was low an
opportunity was virtually unlimited the
people who moved here in 1960 when
Bloomberg graduate high school found
their American dream but things have
changed now the children and
grandchildren of those people are
fleeing California we spent the last
week here in Los Angeles for the show in
some ways it's still a very beautiful
place the western parts of the city are
some of the richest neighborhoods in the
world you'd want to live there their
immaculate nice people but huge swathes
of modern Los Angeles shock the
conscience of anyone who drives by filth
and disorder and clusters of homeless
addicts tent cities continue for block
after block this is footage one of our
producers Charlie Cougars shot yesterday
California has 12 percent of the world's
population but it has a quarter of this
country's homeless adjusted for the cost
of living California is the highest
poverty rate of any state in America
nearly a quarter of its people are poor
why well there are a lot of reasons but
here are some the state has the most
expensive housing in the continent
United States it has the most expensive
gasoline thanks to the taxes the free
world-class universities those are long
gone the University of California system
is some of the highest in-state tuition
rates in the country as we Chronicle
last week in our series American
dystopia no city more accurately
represents the implosion of California
than San Francisco you never know what's
coming around the corner into my arm
I'm not forcing him to move but I taught
him and encouraged him to get to Luke
I'll be telling do you think
yeah you push them out and then what's
day
[Music]
it's messed up really messed up that's
right
and so finally normal people are leaving
California for decades this state led
the nation in attracting migrants from
other states now the flow has reversed
every year the number of people leaving
California for other places exceeds the
number of people moving in by more than
a hundred thousand if it weren't for the
constant stream of immigrants from
abroad California's population would be
falling and fast the middle class utopia
of old has evaporated the state is in
crisis now that's obvious to everyone
who lives here certainly but not to the
people who run California instead of
fixing the problems that are forcing
people to flee politicians here have
spent the last few years on policies
that are frivolous and counterproductive
banning plastic straws requiring
background checks to buy shotgun shells
legalizing the intentional transmission
of HIV governor Gavin Newsom his most
recent budget proposes 80 million in
additional funding to provide free
health care for illegal immigrant
seniors who wants that this is the state
that Democrats are calling the model for
America the state they want your state
to be more like at least you know what
the election is about